you know we love to celebrate our
hospice heroes here in las vegas now so
instead of introducing you to a
volunteer today southwest medical the
sponsors of this next segment want to
educate you on what hospice care
actually is take a look so let's just
start off with defining hospice care and
what that means
sure so hospice provides comprehensive
services for people who are in a the
last stage of their life typically six
months or less
okay and is hospice the place that
you know people must go
during this
actually no that's a myth um almost all
hospice services are provided in a
patient's home and that can be really
anywhere that a patient lives so that
could be a house an apartment a nursing
home group home assisted living and i
know that a lot of people
avoid hospice care because they think
it's expensive is that also a myth tell
us more about that
um that is actually a myth hospice is
covered by medicare and medicaid
and is also typically covered by private
insurance companies
typically there is no out-of-pocket
expense for patients and hospice covers
things like visits from our staff
medications supplies durable medical
equipment
anything really related to the hospice
diagnosis
care includes visits from nurses
other people on our team social services
certain therapies virtual care
things like that that's beautiful a lot
of people don't know those things and
you know some people think hospice care
means there's no more hope or you're
giving up on life let's let's talk about
that and why that's not true either
well you know patients in hospice they
continue to have hopes and goals and
just like anybody else
as a patient's disease progresses the
hospice team really helps patients focus
and their loved ones on what their goals
are at this point and what their hopes
and what can be achieved now ultimately
hospice is really not about dying it's
about living your life to the fullest no
matter how much time you may have left
let's talk about the team and and what a
hospice team consists of
sure so the team of course includes uh
nurses and physicians it can include
social workers spiritual counselors
and bereavement support but it also
includes hospice volunteers
they're a very important part of our
team
so hospice volunteers um you know they
undergo a lot of training and background
checks and they can really just perform
provide that extra layer of support for
the patient and families they can do
such things as provide companionship
support caregivers
you know allow the caregiver maybe to
leave the house for a few hours
they can share stories and memories and
allow the the patient to you know do
some life review
um they can run errands write letters
and sometimes you know it's just
something as simple as setting by the
bedside how can people become hospice
care volunteers if you're interested in
becoming a volunteer you just need to
give us a call
and interview with one of our volunteer
coordinators um you know they can help
you through the process get you set up
for training whatever your interest is
we can find a spot for you
thank you to southwest medical for
sponsoring that segment they have
locations across southern nevada for
more information just call 702-877-5199
or visit smalv.com